today for our daily cancellation we have
a man named James Cy who writes for the
Milwaukee Journal Sentinel and he uh has
just written a column apparently so
poignant and Powerful that it was
reprinted by USA Today and Yahoo news
his article contains a startling
Revelation you aren't going to believe
this but James Cy is a black journalist
who says that he has been the victim of
racism I know it's shocking to hear a
journalist claim that he's been the
victim of racism it's been at least 27
minutes since the last time a journalist
whined about racism so this is this is
not something that happens very often at
all ca's diet tribe has this title I'm
worn from years of racial slurs but I'll
no longer be silent about bigotry now
the article Cy paints a bleak picture
despite being an obscure columnist
writing for a regional newspaper he
apparently gets tons of hate mail he is
a lightning rod for controversy and he
and he complains uh much of the hate
mail is racist so going back 15 years to
when he first started his column he
recounts this
story quote as you might imagine readers
reacted to my writing we get emails and
sometimes phone calls but it was still a
time when we'd regularly get letters in
the mail usually handwritten sometimes
typed out most were positive a few were
uncomplimentary but one stood out after
I wrote a piece critical of Milwaukee
Public School's poor reading scores and
the lack of urgency to change it it was
the first time I'd open a letter to see
myself called the n-word it wasn't the
first time being called out of my life
of course but there was something about
it something something that word seeing
that word written down and used so in in
others that followed black parents were
lazy n-words and I was called an
enabling nword for not calling out the
lazy nword it cut me like a knife 15
years later it still angers me after
years of staying silent about the pain
that it caused and from the other slurs
that fall to this day I came to a
realization this Behavior cannot and
should not be
tolerated so a decade and a half later
and this grown man claims to be actively
in pain traumatized from one one alleged
letter with some bad words 15 years ago
now I have to assert the word insert the
word alleged here because there's no
reason to take him at his word on any of
this and there's plenty of Common Sense
reasons to doubt much of it he continues
claiming that this one racist letter was
only the tip of the iceberg and soon he
was buried under an avalanche of racist
hatred all being uh targeted for some
reason at some guy who writes a column
that nobody reads for a newspaper nobody
reads quote I put the letter in my desk
drawer and didn't tell anyone about it
for weeks a similar letter followed and
another and hundred others all littered
with the same inflammatory language
African-Americans have been called for
hundreds of years sometimes they were
mailed to my house which freaked me out
and scared my wife he then gives some
examples of the things that people have
allegedly said to him reading those
examples verbatim quote when did the
paper start
hiring racial slur that starts with C if
you hate it here so much why don't you
return to Africa and swing from a tree
I'll pay for your one-way ticket the
only thing worse than an n-word is
another n-word in my years as a
columnist not much changed he continues
just the means of delivery sometimes the
hatred comes in via voicemail but
usually it's email now if these all
sound like kind of uh sort of like the
generic racist statements that people
committing race hoaxes always make up
well then draw whatever conclusions you
like um I can't say with certainty that
he's making it up only that it sounds
made up and then there's this strange
anecdote a few months ago I received an
old school mailed letter with a cutout
copy of my column on the annual daddy
daughter dance I talked about the great
times I had with my daughter at this
event until she aged out the sender
presumably a subscriber since it was a
paper copy crossed out the word black
replacing it with the nword
repeatedly okay so he's claiming that
some racist attacked him after he wrote
a column recounting his experience at a
daddy daughter dance and and he says
that this person uh took the time to
cross out the word black wherever it
appeared in the column and replace it
with the
nword well here's the Curious Thing I
read the column which he links to the
daddy daughter column the word black
does not appear at all in the column so
he says that the unknown racist crossed
out the word black and replaced it with
the nword except that the word black is
absent from the article so there's a
slight logistical problem here but we're
not going to linger on it he goes on ask
any black journalists if they have a
similar story I'll bet the answer is yes
we don't discuss it but it's time to
change that if anything the hatred has
become more overt remember the Milwaukee
TV reporter called the n-word at Country
Thunder last summer it's become more
persistent and thanks to social media
easier easier to spew from the
Shadows now I actually do remember that
story about the Milwaukee TV reporter uh
Taylor Lumpkin was her name and she went
to cover some kind of country music
festival and later that night she
tweeted this quote went to cover this
event ton night for a news story left
humiliated after a guy ran up and yelled
at me unprovoked and called me an n-word
twice no one helped everybody stared at
me and laughed do better
people now the odd thing is that Lumpkin
was there as a TV reporter with a TV
crew and yet nobody caught this racist
attack on camera there is no video there
are no photos and this happened
twice so this person came up and ran and
said this nobody turned the camera on
and then he came again and no one turned
the camera on
amazing as far as I could tell no
Witnesses ever came forward so lumpin
made this claim never said another word
about it publicly there was no followup
and then as CI accounts later in this
column she quit her job and left the
industry to focus on her quote mental
health it's all very strange indeed and
by very strange I mean that it obviously
sounds completely made up reading on a
bit more
quote I've long kept the scale of the
racist hatred I Reed to myself often not
telling my editors about it but I've
come to realize how corrosive that is
picture an old house weathered by
Decades of Rain snow hail and other
harsh elements you don't notice the
changes month-to month or even year to
year but when you look at an old photo
you realize how worn it has become it's
like that for me I become weathered and
worn I am
tired now this article goes on like this
and on and on and on it is one extremely
lengthy and tedious Jeremiah ad about
all the persecution he's faced as a
black newspaper columnist in America in
the 21st century and the theme that he
returns to again and again is that he is
tired he's exhausted he's worn down he's
like a man returning home from the
trenches in World War I Shell Shocked
traumatized you cannot imagine the
things he's seen what he's been through
the emails that he's read oh the
emails so many you
emails you know in a world filled with
uncertainties you need to be prepared
for any possibility you need my Patriot
Supply my Patriot Supply is your trusted
partner for emergency preparedness
whether it's a natural disaster a sudden
emergency or unforeseen circumstances my
Patriot supplies high quality food
storage Storage Solutions ensure that
you and your loved ones are always
wellfed no matter what comes your way
right now when you go to prepare
withthomas like their ultimate breakfast
kit a mega protein kit with real meat
and even a gluten-free kit your 3-month
emergency food supply provides over
2,000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations don't wait for disaster to
strike before taking action invest in
your safety and well-being by securing
your food storage today go to prepare
withth walsh.com to get $200 off your
three-month food supply today that's
prepare withth walsh.com now we're not
going to harp on the fact that so much
of the racism he recounts sounds totally
fabricated um and you know I mean that's
that's probably the most Salient point
about all of this but we'll move past it
in order to make one other
point and the point is
this as someone who myself who certainly
gets an order of magnitude more negative
feedback than this guy I can say that
the cliche is true words only have the
power that you give them and people like
James Cy have given a word like the
nword an enormous amount of power not
just James Cy our whole society has
turned this word into something
something more than a word it is like
some kind of Witch's Curse it's a
magical spell it is a collection of
syllables so unspeakably awful that they
cannot be uttered in any context unless
they're being uttered by black people in
which case the word could be said 500
times in every sentence and it's totally
fine so the word is either utterly Bale
and totally meaningless or a mystical in
incantation that holds evil sorcerer
like
Powers which is all completely
incoherent of course but putting aside
the inconsistency in uh in in this uh in
the way that the word is viewed and used
the power it has been given is is
also absolutely arbitrary and
contrived so James Cy says that he read
the word once in in a piece of hate Bale
15 years ago and it still haunts him to
this day like I could not recite
verbatim hate mail I received 15 minutes
ago that there's too much of it and it's
all far too meaningless to me now every
once in a while I get something that's
unusually vile and disgusting even by
current standards and sometimes I get
threats that you know have to be
reported to law enforcement but there is
uh certainly you know there's there's no
word or insult that I could ever read or
hear from a critic that would haunt my
dreams for years and that's because I
don't give my critics that kind of power
guys like KY are the ones who have given
power to these racial slurs but only
certain racial slurs of course
now I don't really believe that kazy has
been lying awake at night in tears over
bad words that people have said to him
but that's the picture he's painting and
all it does is give much greater weight
and impact to the very word that he
claims to
despise so if you really wanted people
to stop using the n-word and you claim
that people are using it all the
time the best thing you could do is
ignore it stop talking about it stop
panicking over it certainly don't write
a 15,000 word lamentation about the pain
that the word causes you
when you do that it advertises to your
critics that they can easily make you
crumple into a little ball and SOB
uncontrollably like a child just by
uttering one simple two- syllable word
in your
presence so it's like if the Wicked
Witch of the West said to Dorothy no
please don't grab that bucket of water
over there and dump it on me of all the
things you could do definitely don't do
that one thing don't do that why are you
doing it I told you not
to in fact come to think of it that's
what you say if you you want someone to
do the thing you say you don't want them
to do so it's almost as if the James
causes of the world give so much
publicity and power to the nword because
they want people to say it he wants to
get the emails he wants to keep the
victimhood train going it's almost as if
this is the most obvious reverse
psychology tactic
imaginable almost as if or exactly as if
I think we've just discovered why the
left makes such a big deal out of that
word
and we've also discovered why James Cy
is today very certainly cancelled if
you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed